let's go to the side
how do you have devotions
how yeah like what do you do
no this is odd i have devotions all day
well i start in the morning yes
you know but all day what do i mean by
that
i am
i'm always on the road
going to supermarket wherever
and i'm always reciting bible verses i'm
thinking what is this saying
what does this mean
trying to make connections between one
passage and another passage i'm
literally always doing it when i say
always i don't mean 24 hours a day every
minute i mean at least every hour
part of the hour i'm going through
passages either reviewing or trying to
learn new passages
and i'm thinking
a few questions what does this tell me
about jesus
because they are there which testify of
me what does this verse teach me about
christ the love of god what does it
teach me about righteousness the central
teaching of the gospel righteousness by
faith what christ does for the sinner
what how does it help me understand some
other passage
and as you recite and you learn and you
fill your head it's easy to compare this
verse with that verse and that verse
this verse and so literally all during
the day when i'm in the gym you won't
believe this but i'll tell you
let's say you're on the bench press you
do a set you know 10 reps
and you take a minute to recover you
i said that's a waste of time just sit
there
let me recite a verse in the beginning
god created
so i started
literally
reciting passages while i'm recovering
so what i would do i would time some
passages usually the psalms
i will lift up mine eyes into the hills
from it's all revelation 15 and see okay
this takes 40 seconds i'll say twice and
i do that
so the time is used
you understand what i'm trying to say
and so i uh that my devotion begins in
the morning but it also goes during the
day
you'll ask my wife she'll tell us as i
go to the darkest part of the house
turn off all the lights and sit on the
floor
and just start thinking
of uh
turn off all the lights so you have no
distractions no nothing think of a bible
verse think on it
what does this say father just dwell on
it dwell on it dwell on it something
else i do that's devotional
i've i'm trying to connect everything to
the bible
for instance
let's say i'm wearing a linen shirt
or cotton shirt where does cotton come
from
a plant
when were plants made
on the third day
am i right am i wrong yes and so you
make a connection immediately between
your shirt and creation are you with me
was it sunny today
it is still sunny
when was the sun made
on day four
who is the son of righteousness
jesus christ
you make that spiritual connection have
you ever driven down the street and you
saw a dead deer dead rabbited dead
something we call it roadkill
did death enter the world
sin
because the curse of adam affected not
only adam otherwise said his rebellion
passed to the animal kingdom and so they
die
and so you a bird flies by they were
made on the fifth day
one day i too will fly through the
atmosphere what i'm trying to tell you
try to make a spiritual connection with
every single if you do that your mind is
so constantly employed with that which
is spiritual the devil is always having
to wait
wait until she thinks about a rock song
wait until he starts rapping then i can
come in
keep the mind on this you see a human
being
they were made on the sixth day
as by one man's sin entered into the
world and death by sin christ became
human you have a fight with your mother
your father
didn't lucifer fight with his creator
jesus christ yes
every single thing
what is the spiritual connection
and in classroom
what's the spiritual connection in the
classroom don't pursue a grade first
pursue a deeper knowledge of god
now you didn't get what i said let me
say it again
and not tell you don't care what grade
you get because i earlier said
excellence god requires i'm saying to
you is let your pursuit of a grade
travel on the track of your pursuit of a
deeper knowledge of god
if you're studying biology
who created life
why do you hesitate who created life god
now you ask yourself where is god in
this cell
where is god in anaerobic respiration
where is god in gaseous exchange in the
lungs because every creator every artist
leaves his or her fingerprints
if you're a musician you can listen to
music and say that's mozart oh that's
handled you look at the painting that's
michelangelo that's whomever that's
picasso
it's the same with god isaiah 6 3 the
whole earth is full of his glory psalm
19 verse 1 the heavens declare the glory
of god and so all of the heaven the
glory of god all of the earth the glory
of god despite pollution you look for
god in accounting didn't he arrange the
tithing system offering euro
everything you study
loy says whatever line of investigation
we pursue with the sincere knowledge to
arrive at truth we are brought into
communion with that mighty unseen
intelligence because all legitimate
knowledge flows from god i say
legitimate crime is not a legitimate
knowledge it did not originate with god
all branches of legitimate knowledge
from accounting to zoology originate
with god and so what i'm telling you
pursue a deeper knowledge of god
and if you do it selflessly the greater
will come
it changes your motivation but the
outcome is the same
because god sees now she's looking for
me in this physics class he's looking
for me in this math class she's looking
for me in this history class i'm a god
of prophecy and the lord will bless your
efforts search for a deeper knowledge of
god
the great will come
you